it was everything living in Russia for
the engine working for the post and
being utterly absorbed in that story in
that really the most important story by
my lights since the end of world war two
was heaven it was journalistic heaven I
even if you were a moron and did nothing
but sit on the stoop of your building in
my case at near October Sky florid
October square you could get a couple of
stories a day seriously people people
who hadn't talked for years and years
and years suddenly will talk to you and
never go away in the best sense possible
and maybe I was even better than that as
a reporter and got around and went
everywhere and it was it was heaven it
was really headed and so when I hear
about report is covering Iraq yes it's
the most important story of its time
conceivably but it's it ain't heaven
it's it's horrible it's it's
unbelievably dangerous and it's
endlessly depressing this was the
opposite it was uplifting it was filled
with human potential and possibility
many of most of which have been
disappointed or dashed at the moment but
it was and it shaped me along
it's it's really very hard to say
because they were you know in 88 clearly
the most important and story beyond the
obvious political Gorbachev Yeltsin
development was was gloss knows than the
publication of everything from Mohammed
ova to saw off to the freeing of soccer
off to publication of social needs in
this kind of thought which which I have
a real taste for and it was
extraordinary see and getting to know
saw her off and and and that circle and
and and and and also really getting to
know the whole Gorbachev circle these
people were knowable it was much easier
to cover Moscow then than it is to cover
Washington today you don't get to know
Bush unless you knew him from the
campaign but with a lot of effort and
coming from a place like the post you
really could know Gorbachev Yeltsin
yakovlev well this this entire circle
you could know it's one remover in
August 1991 I was scheduled to go home
that was it foreign correspondents cycle
app and as almost as a goodbye present I
got an interview with Alexander Yakovlev
who had been the kind of liberal
pelipper remember closest to Gorbachev
by that time he wasn't in there was no
bullet Bureau but he was he was
extremely close to the action knew
everything and we had a long talk and
this was about August fourteenth or so
and he said to me in Russian of course
he said you know David I don't want to
say anything but it's quite possible
that very very soon in this country
there could be a coup led by the KGB and
the military in the Communist Party
against Gorbachev in a circle you don't
say says I and he explained further hey
you know rumors what he intuited etc etc
fine fine fine I wrote this all down and
it was on the front page of the
Washington Post the next day and I got
an airplane and I
left Moscow seemingly for good on August
eighteenth 1991 and I arrived in New
York and around midnight I turned on the
television and there were tanks chugging
down ketosis key prospect right neck
right past my apartment building and I
thought to myself this is horrible for
Russia and almost as bad for me and the
next morning in New York and the East
Coast there was a hurricane essentially
a hurricane a gigantic storm knocking
down trees and flattening all of
Martha's Vineyard and then I thought
there's no way I'm gonna be able to get
on a plane no planes going to leave and
if it does is not going to land in
Moscow I got in this car service with a
little Hasidic man sitting I swear to
God on two phone books he drove me to
Kennedy Airport I got on the one plane
that left the Lufthansa flight I
connected in a no Frankfurt got to
Moscow after only a day of the coup had
not even elapsed and I was not even
jet-lagged and next came home after
Christmas 1991 when the red flag had
gone down over the Kremlin and a red
white and blue one had gone up so you
don't you can't beat dramatic you can't
get more dramatic story than that
you